implies the existence also random
generators
okay so student generators is is really
minimal assumption and cryptography we
can ask whether it is useful uh in
cryptography and uh there are a lot of
interesting Notions uh in cryptography
that are implied by the existence of
surround generators
so for example you can base private key
encryption digital signatures big
commitments and so on uh just on the
existence of surrender generators of
course you can also combine surround
generators with other assumptions to get
even more Primitives
um
so the bottom line is synonyms are very
useful in cryptography
it's also useful in other areas
enterocol science it shows up in
algorithms so we know that if you have
really good children generators then you
can can show BPP equal speed for example
it also uh comes up in complexity Theory
learning theory and so on
okay this was about surrender generators
what about swimmingham Quantum States
and even somewhere on current states are
like very useful in Quantum information
uh so for example sometimes Quantum
States was used to show connection
between wormholes and ads CFT
correspondence
uh it was also used to show some space
complexity lower Bonds in Quantum
machine learning uh it's also uh uh
useful and Quantum complexity Theory
um again the crush must result was
mentioned in the previous talk
okay
um so this is about 300 generators and
Quantum States so we take we can take a
step back and look at the bigger picture
so suram States belong to the you know
this world of quantum cryptography
and sodium generators belong to the
world of classical cryptography so in
Quantum cryptography uh you allow the
algorithms to uh running Quantum
polynomial time you allow for Quantum
communication and so on
the other hand you have classical
cryptography where heuristic the
algorithms to run in probabilistic
polynomial time Communications classical
and so on
so how do we compare these two worlds
right so I should mention that there are
a lot of Works uh uh in especially
showing that these different Primitives
belong to this world uh some of it was
mentioned in the previous talk you'll
hear more about them in other talks
today
okay so how do we compare these two
words
um on one hand
uh Quantum cryptography could
potentially require weaker assumptions
and classical cryptography right so
there are there's some evidence to
believe that that is the case
on the other hand
um Quantum cryptography inherently
requires Quantum communication and in
many places that's that's an issue right
like for example even if quantum
computers do come into existence
tomorrow you really need Quantum
networks also to be uh in place in order
for these applications to be implemented
they're also other places where Quantum
communication creates an issue for
example if you're looking at public key
Primitives and if let's say your public
keys are associated with Quantum States
right
so now there's a problem with
distribution so do you publish many
copies of the state online or like do
you distribute to each user on a on a
user basis so these things need to be
taken into account when you have Quantum
communication
so now the question is can we get the
best of both worlds
so can you get a word where this world
could be could use weaker assumptions
than classical cryptography
on the other hand it just relies upon
classical communication
so that's this is sort of the direction
that we are interested in
and indeed you can consider this world
called as hybrid cryptography where you
allow the algorithms to run in Quantum
polynomial time as in Quantum
cryptography but you enforce that the
communication has to be classical right
right so and there are many Primitives
that come into this class that I've
studied previously uh this is not
something new
so what do we know about hybrid
cryptography the advantages are
um obvious like the the again you just
need classical communication just like
classical cryptography on the other hand
there is a possibility of basing it on
weaker assumptions and Quantum
topography
yeah so
um what I'm going to focus on is I'm
going to look at one primitive in this
class of fiber cryptography that we call
it quantum pseudor random generator
and we're going to look at the
relationship between Quantum So Random
generator and so Random States and also
Quantum serum generator and task
consider random generators
right
okay so what is the Quantum random
generator
um if you are familiar with server and
generators
uh just replace PPT with qpt and you'll
pretty much get the definition
so in more detail
um you know Quantum program generator
has a function associated with it so it
Maps n Bits to M bits and it's important
that M should be larger than n
and just like a classical sodium
generator we require that there is an
efficient algorithm that implements F
and in this case we allow the algorithm
to be qpt
so since the algorithm here is quantum
we have to explicitly enforce the
determinism requirement right so you
want the algorithm to be almost
deterministic so if you run it on the
same key twice then the probability that
you get the same output should be very
close to one so here we allow like
inverse polynomial error
ideally we want this to be negligible
um
but in this talk I'm going to consider
this to be inverse polynomial
okay security is as the same as certain
generators we require that any qpt
algorithm cannot distinguish whether I
get the output of a pseudonym generator
or I get a uniformed random string
yeah definition like conditioned on
outputting correctly like is that
industry from um or GK no no it's just
always the case that's so even if like
your G outputs a bad string with some
inverse poly probability you still want
it to look uniform yes
here I'm only giving one sample like if
I give two samples then it's previously
distinguishable yeah
any other questions
uh because with inverse polymer probably
they might not be the same and here I'm
going to get the same copy twice right
so you have actually two security
requirements one that f is indisting
from random and one that g is indisting
because neither implies the other so
this is the only security requirement we
have uh so F might be distinguishable
from render
uh uh I don't care about whether f is
distinction from random or not all I
care about is the Implement itself
probably not right because there's so
much overlap between gnf yeah because it
implements G approximate itself with
very good probability right it's
certainly stronger that g isn't
distinguished
is this for random K or for every case
just like yes then there could be a big
bunch of case for which f and g this are
different and F happens to be zero on
all of those so let's say G let's say G
is an actual prg just a classical prg
and F is equal to G but on a inverse
polynomial subset of the value is fixed
to zero it depends on what is
excited yeah
okay gesture definition yeah so this
information again the poverty is okay
and the randomness of G okay so then I
agree with yeah so it's mutually the two
things don't imply each other yeah so I
don't care about the initial security
effect I care about this in this
activity
um the reason I specify f is you know I
need to say what does it mean for it to
be vitaministic output and I'm actually
specifies what it needs to be
okay uh any other questions
okay so we're going to look at the
relationship between Quantum and
generators and PRS and prts so first
positive result states that uh you know
any surround state
with logarithmic output
implies the existence of quantum
surround generators
okay I'm going to dive into the results
a bit more so this is sort of the
informal statements and secondly we show
that Quantum generators can be as useful
as classical and generators in many
applications
so for example just like you can use
classical prgs to construct commitments
encryption and so on you can also use
quantum prgs to get these applications
okay okay so let's look at the first
result in a bit more detail so what we
show is that if you have PRS generators
with seed length n and the output length
is some constant times log n should
think of this constant to be something
like it should be at least 10.
uh then this such a PRS implies
existence of quantum Prudential data
of course n to the C Prime should be
larger than n
okay
um and in some sense type because uh
if C is a very small constant then you
can even get this information
theoretically so you need c to be a
large enough constant to show that this
implies existence of quantum prgs
that length extension like when you get
stuff after like you're getting some
fixed polynomial stretch at some points
you won't get pseudo-determinism anymore
right so all these like classical
Transformations don't immediately work
for class uh Quantum prts yeah
these two are just equivalent though
like if you have a quantly computable
string can you just turn it into a
pseudo-random state
the pseudorism is an issue
because uh you know if you if you do the
jealous construction you're going to get
a mixed state
I see but it's like you get the you got
a particular pure state with like a
pretty good probability right no it's
one one or probably away from any pair
of State
and even there's another issue which is
that for Taylor's construction you need
a prf and our PRC and you can't do the
DTM transformation that also is not
going to work you can go from quantity I
mean you just need a long random string
like a little much longer than your
state right so if you're just using like
yeah
okay yeah that's that's the issue I
mentioned like it's going to be worse
okay
okay any other questions
okay at this point is you might be
wondering there is actually a separation
from PRS and uh prds right why doesn't
this contradict that separation so it
turns out that uh if you if you like
look into crash much proof it turns out
that the separation only holds between
super logarithmic out for PRS and prts
so we are not violating any separation
okay
okay so in terms of cryptographic
applications as I said we get all the
applications or many of the applications
that are implied by the existence of
classical prgs uh the one advantage we
have uh in our work compared to the
other uh crypto applications in the
previous papers is that our
constructions are conceptually much
simpler than the previous constructions
in that in the sense that they resemble
the textbook constructions of these
Primitives it's a few
open any crypto 101 textbook you know
you look at the constructions of
commitments and so uh one-time
encryption our constructions resemble
those constructions
and another Advantage is that our
applications only use purely classical
communication
okay
so how do we interpret our results right
so there are two
possibilities so one possibility is that
Quantum prg is really a weaker
assumption than classical prg or
recruiting on incomparable so in either
of the two cases uh it's a win for us
because we can get all these interesting
applications from assumptions that are
qualitatively different from generators
but there's another possibility maybe
Quantum prg and cluster prgs are really
the same we haven't figured out how to
prove it but maybe they're the same
so in that case our result gives an
interesting conceptual message
so since prg is separated from Super
logarithmic uh output PRS
and Quantum prgs can be obtained from
logarithmic output PRS there is a
separation between logarithmic output
PRS and super log in the corporate PRS
so it says that you might potentially
need stronger assumptions to get
logarithmic output PRS than super
logarithmic or PRS to me this was very
surprising you know because in classical
surround generators you can getting
fewer student bits is easier just just
throw away whatever extra surround bits
you have but here it says that like if
you want to get small amount of random
Quantum bits
you probably need stronger assumptions
right and it also says that if you if I
give you a PRS and if you want to
generically shrink the output of PRS to
get something small this this could be
hard as well
so in either of the two possibilities uh
we believe that our work has some
interesting consequences
any questions
okay uh so we also show how to uh come
up with um yeah
sorry
I'm sorry
yes okay so you're saying if you're
given us through a random State on N
base you can ask the first then over two
bits instead it's not clear it's not I
mean if you just throw away you're going
to get a big state and you can show that
if it's very mixed then it's going to be
distinguishable from many copies of our
states
I think the crucial fact is that a uh
the the pseudorandom state generator has
to Output
pure states by definition so around the
states yes almost here uh it's not
not we normally because it always but
it's a fair State as long as it's close
to some peers it's good enough
the PLS
no but in any case if it's close to Pure
State then chopping off something would
not satisfy the definition okay so so in
that trivial sense it's not but but they
wouldn't be distinguishability it's just
that it's it's no longer pure no no it
will be distinguishable so suppose let's
say give you two copies of such a PR
state then there will be distinction
from two copies of the same heart to
your state right just to like a swap
test
Okay so
so but
because of that the nepr state has to be
almost pure
yeah doesn't it seem like there's a
difference in how you define a qprg
versus a PRS
ET like for PRS you need for altk that
like Psy K is like deterministic or like
almost deterministic yeah and here your
requirement is like for a random K that
you're kind of right but why wouldn't
you define it alternatively
alternatively Define it to be that for
all K or almost terministic
we consider like a weaker requirement
that is sufficient for applications and
we can also build it from login to PRS
it's pretty observative you can consider
the stronger emotion yeah I feel like
the other one would probably be
equivalent to prss problem that's true I
don't say it's equal because One
Direction I can see to go to PRS learn
how to go from PRS to this kind of a
KPLC just just because of the like the
continuous nature like there will always
be some reverse problems
you will see when you when we talk about
the techniques then you get some more
additional as to why we can't get
it okay uh any other questions
but
yeah so we also consider uh Quantum yeah
sorry so if you go back
really curious so you're saying well
um yes sir they are distinguishable
because because now these are these are
not pure States anymore yeah
now you're saying well it really has a
consequence and it's a consequence of
the same nature or is it of a different
nature so
so uh you know now I don't understand
this uh this possibility too so can you
put some tea you know can you okay can
you sort of say
can you sketch out what it is what is
the call for these consequences yeah
yeah because now okay I don't understand
where it's coming from right so uh right
so um we want to understand how
different is logarithmic hardcore PRS
functions
yes
um is it there the same assumption or
are they separated no I don't know I
understand that it may not be the same
assumption right the sense that
um you know in the sense that there's
this mixtape issue but but now are you
saying that because of this you know we
might think okay well this hit mixtape
issues the technicality you know sort of
it's hardly defined it but but you're
actually saying no no it has a
consequence yes for something else now
is that is is there is that consequence
of the same nature or different Natures
are you saying no no but uh these are
actually stronger objects than than you
would imagine because you can do this
kind of Photography it's not just
different because of the changes right
so the consequences that uh uh here the
consequences are more of a conceptual
message rather than getting some
concrete cryptography complications the
conceptual message is just that you
might need stronger assumptions stronger
computational assumptions
to get smaller amount of so Random
qubits versus large numbers of random
words to me this is like surprising
because classically you know getting
small amount of certain Randomness is
easier in some cases you know strictly
is you're getting they're getting a
um so there's no like applications per
side here it's just about understanding
how like clockwise
okay wait so let's move on
okay so we also get 200 functions so and
we have some similar applications for
performance around functions as well
okay so let me uh jump right into the
techniques
um so it turns out that to show the
positive result which is what I'm going
to be focusing on uh I want to talk
about the crypto applications
so to get the positive results uh it
turns out that our main tool is to get
an extractor where the extractor gets us
input many copies of a state PSI right
and it outputs a binary string
so what are the two requirements on this
extractor so One requirement is that you
want this to be generated so
domestically
what this means is that if you run the
extractor again on T fresh copies of the
states I then you should more or less
get the same strength
that's the first requirement the second
requirement says that if PSI is a horror
random state
then y size should be distributed
according to the uniform distribution
okay so so these are the two
requirements and we will see how to
achieve it
so let's start with the thought
experiment so we'll come with an
extractor that's not physically
implementable but it helps to think
about it
so uh we're going to look at a
deterministic ideal extracted that has
two properties so the first property is
the determinism requirement
that says that if the extractor is given
amplitudes of a hor random state right
then it outputs F of PSI where F of PSI
is f is a continuous function that maps
all the points in the unit sphere to uh
binary strings
so you can think of like partitioning
the units we are into many regions and
each region is associated with a binary
string
okay and we wanted the probability that
it outputs F of psi should be very close
to one
in terms of security requirement we just
want that the output distribution of the
extractor should be uh close to the
uniform distribution
okay so how do we come up with this
extractor so the initial hope would be
that maybe from every amplitude I can
extract some bits of Randomness but
that's just not possible because all the
amplits are correlated with each other
right you want the sum of squares of
hundreds to one right so you can't hope
to extract from all of them but what if
we discard some of the amplitudes
so then maybe I can still like extract
some uniform Randomness from the rest
right so that's what we are going to do
so we're going to use a fact about uh
uniform spherical measure which is the
following so if you yeah
yes yes for now I'm gonna do that later
on we'll try to come up with a physical
like
okay so I'm going to what this fact says
is the following so if you pick a random
point on the unit sphere and if you
throw away some coordinates
then they're going to be close to the
gaussian distribution okay ID cost and
distribution where the mean is zero and
uh uh and the variance is like standard
deviation is going to be 1 over d
okay
and how many coordinates are we throwing
on I mean so let's say we are only
considering K coordinates then the the
total variation distance between uh the
first K coordinates and K IIT questions
is going to uh is going to look like
this
so all you need to remember is that we
are going to work in uh the polynomial
Dimension space which means that D is
going to be some polynomial okay
so note that we are going to apply this
for logarithmic output PRS which means
that we are working in like polynomial
Dimension uh Hilbert space
and then we should think of K to be
something sublinear in D so if you
substitute the parameters you're going
to get the total variation distance to
be convertible amount
that's all you need to remember right
now
okay so what are we going to do so we
have these different uh amplitudes given
to us
so we're going to discard
some number of them towards the end and
we know that like each of them is close
to I uh gaussian distribution
okay
so this gives a natural rounding
mechanism
so what I'm going to do is if this
amplitude I'm going to look at the real
components yeah
for the alphas they're supposed to be
the gaussian like complex gaussian
coefficients of a high random state
the amplitude itself
I see and your problem is that you want
to deterministically turn this into a
random classical string yes like
supposing that you have a mechanism for
learning all of these applicants yes and
you're saying you can't just output the
amplitudes because they're normalized
and so they're actually not like yes
exactly
okay sorry thanks so I'm going to look
at the real components right and each of
the real components are going to be
close to the Arabic also
so then this gives rise to a natural
rounding mechanism so what I'll do is
that if this is above zero then I'm
going to extract the bit uh zero okay if
it is below zero if if the real
component is below zero then I'm going
to extract the bit to be one
this is how I'm going to extract uh the
bits from all the amplitudes
so just to do it like a very simple
exercise
um so if I have like four uh amplitudes
here so I'm going to look at the real
components
um so the real component here is zero
so then the first case you know you have
the value to be larger than zero so
you're going to extract the bit to be
zero second case it's one third case
it's zero because the uh real part is
zero and fourth case should zero right
so you're going to Output 0 1 0 0.
okay
yeah of course this is uh so the third
experiment it worked great but it was a
thought experiment you can't really hope
to get all the amplitudes in the clear
um so that's the first issues like how
do you come up with a physical
implementation of this extractor
and the second issue is that there's
still like uh one over two to the N
total variation distance from from the
uniform distribution
and you might think that this is this is
not that much right like I mean it's
just negligible in n
but note that we are working in the
setting where n is something logarithmic
so you're going to get the total
variation distance to be inverse
polynomial with uniform yeah if all I'm
doing is taking the science of a random
State why do I need a draw some of the
entries yeah because they're correlated
with each other you have to argue that
they're going to be uh
right well let's say you couldn't
understand I mean aren't these kind of
the parodies of the signs
I'm extracting all the bits yes
yes but aren't the signs I'm correlated
with each other
um
okay if that is true then you can do
that you don't even have to throw it uh
so we're relying on this result or you
know this is how we were able to argue
that data
oh yeah happy to talk about it
but are the signs kind of physically
you're I mean the consecutive science
like sorry look at the parity between
zero and one and then one and two and
two and three and those are going to be
independent binary like plus minus ones
I I have problems as soon as complex
numbers come into this picture because
it's all up to Global phase so is it
kind of like you ask none of this is
physical right I'm going to come up with
other implementation where we'll take
all these things yeah sure it's not
physical but I mean kind of it's even
less physical if we are talking about
the actual like yes there's one problem
State I can't figure out yes those those
Alphas but there's the additional
problem that give them a state that is
actually
uh I mean they aren't really pure States
they're pure State modular Global phase
and then these values are not even
mathematically well defined and that's
my problem right so right now just think
of them as me giving many complex
numbers from some distribution yeah
I wouldn't say even better something
that is implemented
okay
um Okay so
there are two issues as I just pointed
out
um so second issue let's just ignore it
you can extend some known classical
security amplification techniques to
deal with this so let's just focus all
our attention on the first one
how much time do I have
okay okay let me try to uh
um increase the pace
okay so let's come to something that's
more physical
um so in this case like I'm not going to
give you the amplitudes in the clear of
course so what I'm going to give you is
many copies of a heart state right
um again it's exponential in N number of
copies of the heart state
uh and then the goal is still the same
as before I want to Output some string
um that is sort of two-dimensic with
very high probability
okay
um and I don't want this to hold for all
the states I I just want this guarantee
to hold for State side that belongs to a
good set
I'm not I'm going to argue that if a
state is a horrendous state if if you
sample the state from the hard random
distribution then with very good
probability it's going to belong to the
good set
okay
so condition on the state being in the
good set
you know the extractor is going to be
students with a very high probability
right
okay so we don't have this like very
nice picture earlier where like we
divide into different regions there are
some gray Parts where you know we have
no guarantees whatsoever but in the
other regions we can sort of extract the
string with very high probability
okay so there are two steps in the
description of the extractors the first
is to perform tomography second is the
surrounding procedure so the first step
is more standard so once you if you have
if I give you enough number of copies
you can sort of recover classical
description on the state
um so we have the state that is like
close to uh the density Matrix
associated with the the harder end of
State PSI
so since they are going to be close to
each other so I'm going to work with
this even though I don't get this uh in
the in the execution of the extractor
for the analysis I'm going to work with
this
okay
okay so once you get the the you know
output from the tomography procedure the
next step is to do some rounding right
to extract the uh uniform bits out of it
so all I care about are the diagonal
entries you know the other entries are
not important to me
okay
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
throw away some columns okay
and the diagonal entries I'm going to
divide into different blocks
and then I'm going to sum up all the
entries in each block
so I can show that uh each of these
entries forms a
is as if we were sampling from a
chi-square distribution so if you sum up
all of them we can use Central limit
theorem to show that they're going to be
close to the normal distribution
so you can do that for every coordinate
oh sorry every block
okay
right so you can consider the first
block some of all the entries in that
block to get q1
consider the second block some of all
the entries in that block to get Q2 and
so on uh and all these different qis are
close to IID gaussians so the the mean
is not going to be zero anymore it's
going to be shifted but that's that's
not a problem
okay so what is going to be the rounding
procedure just to sum up summarize so
we're going to discard some columns uh
and then you're going to bring the
diagonal entries into different blocks
and then sum up all the entries in each
block okay and then you're going to do
the rounding procedure so since they are
close to IIT questions so you're going
to for each coordinate you're going to
around depending on whether it's higher
than the mean or lower than the mean
okay so this is this is going to be the
mean
so if it is higher than the mean you're
going to classify it to be zero if it is
lower than the mean you're going to
classify to be one
okay
okay so this is all like assuming that
we had this actual Matrix I PSI
but of course you don't have the access
to that you have whatever you get out of
the tomography procedure
right so if you work with this
um even though they're close to each
other there might be an issue right
because the tamagra there is a error
that results in the tomography procedure
uh and how does the error affect us
so if the QI values were very close to
the mean even even if one of one of the
QI values was very close to the mean
then the tomography error could be so
large that in every single time you run
you're gonna get zero and one with maybe
the same probability
and that's bad right so you really want
the QI values to be very farther away
from mean as possible
so that's how I'm going to define the
notion of good States right so there's
the set of good states are going to be
uh
I'm going to call it state of uh state
to be good if all the QI values are far
from the B
so that the tomography procedure
whatever error that results in the
tomography procedure uh doesn't cause a
classification error
and then you can show that with high
probability any High random state is
going to belong to this set
this uh it's not something I want to
talk about but you can sort of show this
so this was all this discussion was
about coming up with an extractor how is
this useful to go from a logarithmic
output PRS to Quantum prgs so here's
what I'm going to do I'm going to run
the PRS many many times to get many many
copies of the pr state
um and then I'm going to run the
extractor on many many copies of the
state to get YSI and then I'm going to
Output myself
okay
okay yeah
that's still an issue so that's why you
only get one over poly determinism error
it also causes an issue and security but
there we do some security amplification
techniques to get negligible
for correctness we don't know how to get
get rid of it
um if you if we would get rid of that
part I mean this
uh distance from uniform in the sampling
would that help us because we still have
the tomography error which makes it so
the deterministic so would we get any
advantage if we solve this problem so if
you manage that is true yeah because I
think you could do it by just adding an
extra seat and using classical
Randomness extractor based on that so I
think this sounds like the solvable part
of it but I'm not sure but also I'm not
sure like I think the the the fact that
we used
their monopolies like the best we can do
whatever even if you are somehow it can
help with another argument to solve that
issue tomography
thanks
okay so that's how we get a quantum PLC
um and then you can show that uh the
output distribution is computational
distinction from unit
by relying upon the security of PRS okay
okay so this concludes the you know so
the high level description of uh getting
quantum prg
so let me sort of give you some open
questions to think about
so I divide this intermediate area that
is sandwiched between Quantum
cryptography and classical cryptography
and our work sort of explores the
connections between PRS and classical
prgs
via this primitive
so one interesting question that we
still don't know how to solve is is
classical prgs and Quantum prgs that
different
can you show a separation between both
of them that's something that we don't
know how to do
or maybe there is uh no separation right
in which case can you show that like
logarithmic output PRS and super lock on
the counter PRS are separated from each
other so
either of the two questions should be
true can you solve any of them
sorry um and then um another thing is
that this there's a inverse polynomial
error can you can you reduce the error
to be negligible right like so somehow
if you come up with another argument as
for me was mentioning you can then show
that such a notion of quantum prts and
logarithmic or PRS are going to be
equivalent to each other
this is another open question
um
either prove an impossibility or a
positive result and finally
um
you know we show that uh this is related
to the previous question we show that
logarithmic order PRS implies Quantum
prgs but it can somehow show that
Quantum prg implies logarithmic
outputers
they still don't know how to solve this
problem as well
so with that uh I conclude
[Applause]
now there are two problems with this one
is that I don't know how to go from
Quantum free org to Quantum prf directly
first of all like if you try to Define
quantum prf that itself is going to be
in Ontario so somehow let's say you
managed to do that I don't know how to
go from Quantum prg to Quantum PR and
the classical Digimon the transformation
does not work that's the first problem
second problem is you have to still
solve the inverse polynomial
because even if you got Quantum erf with
the inverse problem will error
you I don't know how to get PRS from
that
so
there's something that uh kind of
confusing here
um so you know in classical complexity
Theory there's this theory on this stock
market here which is about counting the
number of solutions and the way through
the works you say well if you could
count and you can apply some random hash
of the solution and you can approximate
the calculator seeing does there exist
something which is a solution in
simultaneously the hash
so if you have this map that takes the
you know the higher measure it extracts
out these classical values doesn't it
apply something very strong
for this Quantum approximately
I thought those were not known to exist
like what what is the consequence
basically it's like the
um the Hilbert space there's no way of
like halfing it you
know right so here I don't know whether
the the determinism error is predicted
to your question like you don't know how
to how to actually
divide the like the region exactly in
such a way that again like designate
regions to each right there's always
like boundaries where you're gonna mess
up I don't know whether that is going to
cause a problem in extending the result
we can talk more offline
thanks for your first answer to tell me
this question
um
random States
a random function you can basically
create a random state of like very short
output lengths
that should only require a polynomial
number of random bits to instantiate
when your qubit length is very small I
think this question was different so
he's asking whether you can go from
logarithmic or PRS so let's say super
logic generically
oh okay sorry I thought you were asking
whether you can go from
PR Quantum prg to log out of a PRS
oh okay so never mind but this is also
an interesting in general
okay the other thing I was wondering is
um like you're talking about sort of
assumptions weaker than away functions
um but I guess you know there's a
there's a lot of things that are
eventually weaker than only functions
and it feels like maybe on that sliding
scale of like how weak things are this
is like pretty pretty close to one eye
functions right and that like if pgp
equals qma these don't exist but then
there's still all this other stuff
honestly I don't know I don't know
whether it is really close to that's why
I raised the two possibilities in the
talk
either way I think this is saying
something interesting like we can show
that it's also why functions that would
be amazing right I guess close in the
sense that there are
collapses that would actually
for those same classes wouldn't rule out
like
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
it is uh closer in terms of like
computational assumptions compared to
positive crypto right sure yeah
uh but yeah I mean very interesting to
to understand yeah so this implies a
pseudo deterministic one-way function
doesn't it yes it says qprd is a Quantum
on a function if you can definitely
yeah the question is
so
um
no I think the problem is that we
thought about signatures so the problem
is that the Surah chromosome is not
causing error like whenever you run the
same thing twice
you might be able to sort of distinguish
whether this word or the other one
this issue doesn't matter for prg
because I'm always going to give you
only one sample but whenever you are
sitting where I have to give you
multiple samples on the same input
you're in trouble
any other questions
okay sorry I took up a lot longer than
I'm supposed to uh
thanks if you have any questions
um please ask me often
um we have a long lunch break until one
and then
yeah
difficult